mas ela estava jogando um jogo chamado
grampo smo e aí logo no começo eu
comecei com camarão camarão são [ __ ]
moleque corria a [ __ ] corria para
desgraça e eu fazia curvas de boa um
leque botava 204 254 260 por hora e
avançou o jogo até que esteve uma hora
eu só podia jogar uma corrida tentar
fabricado antes de 1979
leza o ir lá comprar o carro aí cheguei
na concessionária e logo de cara
adivinha o tempo todo feito em fusca mas
porque isso tudo ilhas
eu vou contar agora pra vocês quando era
pequeno meu pai pede um fusca
eu era muito apegado a esse fusca
gostava muito desse fuso a minha vida
quando eu era pequena era esse fusco eu
adorava andar nesse fusca e eu não
queria andar em outro carro não sei se
furta tomava de mais este carro tem uma
história
como eu já falei pra vocês a minha irmã
precisou ser operada do coração ea minha
família não tinha um centavo para fazer
cirurgia
estiveram que vendesse cá é galera
e se fosse ouvida
e aí eu comecei ajeitar ele começar a
modificar nele pra ver se o bicho
contava pra correr
o de suspensão mudei pneu e ele virou um
novo fluxo que eu chamei de frederick pe
o [ __ ]
frederico virou a marca e não um leque
pátria ufa come ninguém eu competia com
um chevette com pq tu ônibus carro feito
20 anos à frente ou frederico votava a
favor bem nas curvas negão eo emelec
fazia cuba não há precisão um gay já viu
só que o frederico as vezes que se que
era um vôo foi aí que o frederico se
acidentou
ele estava modificado
ele estava forte mas ele continuava
sendo um fusca
mas frederico schmidt muita força de
vontade
frederic queria continuar
federico voltou e tentou
não tinha condições frederico ganhar
pela curriculum felix abalou com a
seguinte eu não conseguia mais fazer
curvas com aquela maestria que ele fazia
mas frederico não parou
a última coisa que eu queria que eu
queria era terminar aquela corrida
parada e olhava por federico lembrava
aquele mesmo carro que salvou uma fina e
ele tentou tentou tentou e terminou a
corrida
ah
ae